if you're sitting there right now on
amazon thinking of buying a pair of
airpods
stop take your finger off that add to
cart button
because there's a good chance we're
getting some brand new airpods very soon
and even if you're not looking to buy a
brand new pair
you should wait because the current
airpods will likely go on sale for some
really good deals
when the new ones get released so in
this video i'm going to go through a
bunch of leaks and rumors
that talk about the new airpods pro 2
and the new airpods 3
and when exactly we should be expecting
these new airpods to get released
so let's quickly go through a long
history of airpods leaks and rumors
so we can see what adds up way back in
february of last year
it was reported that apple was working
on airpods pro
lite basically having the design of the
pro model
but without the noise cancellation
features and then in april
it was reported that those airpods could
actually be the new
airpods 3 model so the basic airpods
will simply take on the pro design going
into the future
and then they also mentioned that they
would be delayed
potentially into 2021 because of kovind
ming chukwu also confirmed that report
by claiming the airpods 3
will be coming in the first half of 2021
but he says the design will be unchanged
on the outside
with new internals on the inside like a
new chip
however in june he changed his mind and
said that the airpods 3
will actually have a similar design to
the pro model
so this seems the most likely moving on
in may
digitimes also reported that apple was
going to pack
ambient light sensors into a set of air
pods in the future
and apple track's take on that rumor was
that apple would use those sensors
to measure your heart rate and other
biometrics
making it even more interesting love to
dream
the very reliable twitter leaker claimed
in june
that sometime in the future airpods will
be coming with a totally wireless design
meaning that the lightning port will be
going away now in my opinion
i can only see this happening when apple
does eventually
ditch the charging ports on their
iphones but i guess we're gonna have to
wait and see
then in july digitimes reported that new
2021 airpods in airpods pro
will be made in vietnam and other
sources
claimed that the third generation
airpods will be released in the first
half of 2021
with the new airpods pro in the second
half now moving on to october
mark german once again confirmed the
previous reports
that the airpods 3 will look like
airpods pro
but without the high-end features like
noise cancellation
again launching in the first half of
2021
and here is where it starts to get very
very interesting
mark german also claimed that the
airpods 2 will come with a brand new
circular design and an upgraded wireless
chip
potentially the h2 expected to come
sometime
in 2021. this actually makes a whole lot
of sense because if apple is changing
the basic airpods design to match the
current pro model
they need to update the design of the
pros to stand out
and look more premium or packing more
features
now other already existing wireless
earbuds like the amazon echo buds
and the galaxy buds pack a circular
design
that fits into your ears without
sticking out and we actually
love that about them because it's more
convenient and comfortable to for
example change your clothes
and this design also allows for a larger
battery as well
moving on apple in october was granted a
patent
for in-air gesture input for airpods
so if the new airpods pro don't come
with the stem
this sort of technology for controls
would actually make sense
as long as apple can pull it off they
also included a couple of other ideas
like putting in a tactile structure like
a crown
on the airpods themselves which doesn't
seem very likely
but hey they already added it to the
airpods max
so who knows getting even more weird
apple was granted a patent for a new
technology
that is able to detect things like
clicking your teeth
to control your music which just sounds
insane
moving on ming chi kuo then claimed that
the airpods 3
will actually have a sort of hybrid
design
somewhere in between the airpods 2 and
the pro
and he claimed that they'll be coming in
either april may or june of 2021
and then here's the banger 52 audio
leaked a component
from the airpods 3 which looks kind of
like the pros
but without the in-air seal design
apparently featuring a shorter stim
like we've been hearing from these leaks
and the crazy thing is that 52 audio
was actually the site which leaked the
original airpods pro design
before it was released so this new leak
could actually be coming true
the elec also claimed that these new
airpods 3 would cost 199
with an h1 chip inside coming in the
first half of 2021
so all of this is really starting to add
up and make sense
and now here's a leak that's going to
totally blow your mind
mr white shared a photo of an airpods
component
in black yes there's a chance that we
could
actually finally get black airpods for
the first time
now i don't know about you but i think
this could totally sell a ton
of airpods since this is a long
requested feature
by a lot of apple fans now if we take a
closer look at this photo
it actually matches the insert of the
top of the current airpods pro
but the cutouts don't seem to look as
curved
they seem like they would actually match
the more boxy shape
of the airpods 3 that 52 audio
previously leaked so based on that it's
seeming more
and more likely that we'll be getting a
black color option
for air pots and just a couple of days
ago we received the final rumor from mac
atakara claiming that the new airpods
pro are launching in
april but with a slightly different
shaped case
so with all of those leaks out of the
way we can sort of see how the pandemic
delayed the release of the airpods into
2021
and it's pretty amazing how many of
these different sources
agree on both models of the airpods a
lot of the rumors pointed to the airpods
being released in the first half of 2021
which means a release date of june or
earlier
with that final leak pointing to april
which makes a lot of sense
since apple is rumored to be releasing a
ton of products in march
and of course they have their wwdc event
in june
it's also interesting to see how older
rumors pointed to the airpods 3
having a shorter stem just like the pros
and then we finally saw that leak from
52 audio
showing the new design and remember he
was right
about the original airpods pro design so
everything that we saw in his leaked
design
matches up to all of the other leaks and
rumors
and the rumored 199 dollar price tag
also makes the most sense as well
and if his leak is true that means
they're already finished with the design
and they're probably going to be ready
to ship very soon
so april does make a lot of sense
however
i don't expect the airpods 3 to get
released
with that new design before the new
airpods pro 2 are released
so in my opinion it actually makes the
most sense
to release both models at the same time
i feel like
apple was initially planning to space
out the release dates
but because of the pandemic one of the
new designs was delayed
so they might just release both of them
at once in april this would give people
a choice between the two
allowing apple to upsell the pro model
for a higher price
most likely close to 300 and on top of
that
if apple does come out with a black
color option this would entice a lot of
people to upgrade
even just for the color alone which is
crazy to think about
and then once those airpods are released
there's a good chance that the current
models
will be discounted and go on sale before
all of the stock runs out so if you're
thinking about buying airpods right now
definitely wait until april for those
new models
because if the rumors and leaks are true
they're gonna be amazing
but of course if you can't wait that
long some of them are actually
already on sale right now on amazon so
i'm gonna leave some links to them down
in the description below hopefully this
video helped you out and if it did go
ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle about to subscribe
for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]